I've almost finished my diagram there's
something missing from it what's missing
the shading very good the actual thing
you're trying to work out the reason why
I've left off from doing that is because
this shape here that's been shaded is
actually not just one shape it's the
difference between two shapes but
they're not shown okay
so this is why we call them compound
areas if you think back to like
composite shapes and that kind of thing
it's like this is made up of multiple
pieces right you can get that by finding
the right pieces in here okay so I'm now
going to highlight the pieces for you if
you have another color on you or pencils
that you can shade with or something
like that then you can do this alongside
me if you look at this shape without
anything shaded okay I have a part of
this area that's underneath the parabola
it's this part this power here is
underneath the parabola it's an area
under a curve which means we can find it
by what technique integration that's
what this whole topic is about which is
very convenient because in this case
it's an awkward shape it's not a nice
like there's not there's not a straight
line it's not even a semicircle so I
have to use integration to do that now
look at this black area the one I've
shaded how are we going to form an
integral that will find the size of that
area I'll say integral okay very good
just before you go under D I'm looking
for boundaries here because it's an area
that starts somewhere and ends somewhere
so nnedi you can go on again negative
one okay now if I went to zero I get
this part here which should be fine and
then I could do this part over here
however notice that like I can think of
this just as one area I know it's two
pieces but they're both underneath this
same curve do you agree so I could stop
at zero and then pick up again but I
can't just go all the way to the end
what is the end it's four you can read
it off that x value there so I'm gonna
go from negative one to four okay
that's the boundaries can someone else
pick up from where nadir left off and
tell me what to write after
what's the curve I'm under D X squared
right there's the equation right there
that's why they handed it to you X
really need a refill
DX okay why did I say DX what does that
signify apart from the thing that you
just always say after integrals I know I
wanted black I'm kind of blue in a
second sorry I'm picky
DX means with respect to with respect to
X for two reasons
it's there that's the variable thank you
I'm spoiled go be careful
you used to this oh that's the variable
I'm interested but this is a this is
geometric reason why it's X there's a
geometric reason why it's X it's a
function of X and which axis am I going
to go into the x axis later on you're
going to not go to the x axis you're
going to sometimes go to the y axis and
that won't be DX it'll be do you want
okay good so we know what this thing is
it's the area that I've just shaded okay
well to get this one the one that they
actually want right it's the difference
between this area and which are the one
can you see it
it's the whole area underneath what's
the shape of it you can tell me what
it's got to start with a team it's a
trapezium okay so I'm gonna try and do
it like this I'll do it sideways so
that's your pzm right if you work out
the area underneath that straight line
what's its equation 3x plus 4 you work
out its area underneath it it doesn't
just stop at the parabola right because
when you write the integral to do with
that it's still gonna start at negative
1 still going to go to 4 the integrand
is 3x plus 4 but what are you gonna put
after that you're going to put DX which
means go to the x-axis so it just goes
right down the bottom okay so the area
they want is the difference between
these right it's gonna be this guy
takeaway come back oh no I forgot which
ones which cross your fingers that
aren't that proud of the one you told me
before
you see that it's the difference okay
now I've actually come up with an
expression that's the real area I want
so I'm actually going to call this
capital A for area
okay now properties of definite
integrals think back to last year and
this is gonna be reaching back a little
bit for some of you
properties of definite integrals if you
have two definite integrals
and their boundaries are the same you
see that about negative one and four I
can combine these into one piece okay
you mind them two one
so I'm gonna do that instead of writing
two integrals which both have the same
boundaries I'm just gonna write one
integral that shares those boundaries so
I've got 3x plus 4 and I heard it before
someone suggested they preempted me I'm
gonna subtract this x squared take away
what's underneath the parabola like so
okay two integrals into one do you have
to write this intermediate Lion the
short answer is no but I'm going to
encourage you to do that because this
shows me that I I can see what you're
thinking here's an area here's another
area I subtract them it's an important
process for your brain to go through
rather than I just write this magic line
that will give me the correct answer in
a second okay from here I reckon you
guys could take over right you can find
the primitive of that you can evaluate
it at your upper lower boundaries get a
number out why don't you go ahead and do
that see what you come up with